[Music]
are these the only three things dolls
have been use for toys collectors items
and demonic conduits asking for a friend
also looks like this movie should give
credit to my freshman thesis dolls from
Barbies to Bratz a raggedy ANNs tail
maybe it will also get a b-minus from my
children's playthings professor all she
wanted was to be friends when we heard
this weave we felt really sorry for her
I mean we're nurses we help people I
don't believe the Hippocratic oath lends
itself to forcing you to help possessed
dolls who very well may want to kill you
also we have to sit through a basic
retread of the opening scene from the
conjuring since probably 90% of the
people that see this movie are watching
because they thought the doll and the
conjuring was creepy this scene is
pointless I don't know where she got hit
but we are beyond terrified and the
thought of putting it in a trunk
wrapping it up in Chains locking that
inside a larger trunk wrapping it in
Chains tying a huge rock to it and
dumping it in the ocean never occurred
to you Church has creepy horn demon
statue that convenient level tie into
the plot of this movie in case you
confused it with Santa Monica
Oklahoma God on their sacrifice and our
sacrifices touch God's heart and move
his hand opening shot a foreshadowing
sermon is very foreshadowing also
discount F Murray Abraham we are
introduced to our main characters being
disrespectful dicks in church also the
thumb wrestling your pregnant wife in
church also thumb wrestling voyeurism
the one isn't this thumb wrestling thing
this couple has delightful it's their
thing it gives them such richness and
character Sharon get off Pete send you
after me
well no we simply asked where you were
and then I volunteered to find you and
it was really stupid because you were
easily found in the chapel but the
screenwriter gets to check off your
introduction in the first 30 pages of a
script so he's happy children are a
blessing indeed they are and the mid
learn to talk haha banter banter white
people joke banter banter we shouldn't
talk about the baby so much in front of
them
right first off you assholes are
neighbors so how is it not the main
topic of conversation second off you
assholes didn't even bring up the baby
they were sharing but again you want to
give us that insight about them losing
their daughter so you chose the awkward
path to telling us that they call
themselves between this news report and
the previous few minutes of awkward
conversations about kids this is a lot
of exposition for the first six minutes
of a movie hard to concentrate I
couldn't even hear the TV over the
loudest sewing machine ever movie cast
actress Annabelle Wallis in a movie
called
Annabelle now she's plenty good enough
for this role but you've got to think
the producers of this movie chose her at
least halfway based on the name alone
right guys you probably shouldn't let
John kiss the baby bump so recklessly
because Sharon and Pete next door can
sense you guys being happy about it
she's something I want to give you the
last time you said that I ended up
pregnant John and Mia have a stand-up
comic exchange circa 1930s did the
ghosts of Bob Hope and George Burns
write this movie there was no way this
dude hit a giant box with a prize doll
in it from his pregnant wife inside the
house without her stumbling upon it at
least once you'll be a little short on
the rent the next few months like that
once our landlords find out that I spent
some of that rent on a rare doll to
complete a collection they'll be sure
not to evict after me a complaint
earlier in the day about leaving the
door unlocked
they leave their window open while they
sleep
all of this happens in Plainview and Mia
wakes up because she feels a disturbance
in the force but unfortunately this
murder turns the light off before she
can see anything
also Sharon insted eyes so everything in
the neighboring house is completely
silent after she screams one time also
also for this shot to happen these
couples are super okay with leaving
their windows uncovered at night
directly facing each other's bedrooms
also also also this jump-scare is the
only scary thing that happens in the
entire movie and it doesn't even involve
the creepy doll that the entire movie is
supposed to be about don't mind me I'm
just walking around being creepy I serve
no function at all right now there's
gotta be a good 20 other dolls in that
room it's as if the woman knew she was
about to die and have her soul go into a
doll so she wanted to pick the one that
would scare the people the most also we
find out later that this is Pete and
Sharon's daughter Annabelle and her
boyfriend and so it makes sense that
they would kill her parents for some
stupid reason so why are they fucking
around with Mia is this guy been hiding
in this closet the whole time how the do
these psychics manage to travel through
space and time to enter impossible areas
then patiently wait and hide in places
until it's time for them to be scary
dicks again come on guys it is way too
easy for dolls to get possessed by
murderers if all it takes is a drop of
their blood at least have this chick do
an incantation or a Harry Potter spell
I'll drop a blood are you kidding me
what officers summed up these
blood-soaked murders by saying in all my
years I have never seen any he went on
to say but after all it is my first day
on the job yes have to pay for me this
diatribe Mia gives John about saving the
baby over her is this obvious as
foreshadowing gets but there is no
incident for the rest of the film where
this notion comes into play and nothing
is said about it ever again
Annabelle just discovering her new ghost
powers decides that using a sewing
machine in the middle of the night is
the best use of those powers but I'm
beginning to think all new ghosts and
demons are given a fucking handbook when
they become self-aware and rule one is
dew point leap in the middle of the
night to annoy the living also this
scene from start to finish is close to
four minutes there's a good 45 seconds
of John trying to figure out how to turn
the sewing machine off Snoopy is 90%
padding the scene is so beautifully lit
and staged that it makes it all the more
irritating that the entire scene
revolves around a sewing machine turning
itself on this is the best looking piece
since alien 3 I'll tell you what it is
stuff that Annabelle is underneath this
dresser and not on the shelf where we
lost Tsar because that means with the
freedom of movement she decided to hide
underneath a dresser rather than finding
a way to hitch a ride to the Maldives I
mean ball dives I mean all this would be
scary if I hadn't seen fourteen hundred
and fifty nine other rocking chair
moments and horror movies before
well I'm done rockin for today that was
good enough to get her curious must be
that room you have to love 60s male
logic about how electronics work
pregnant women love pickles cliche for
we are me together yeah I know like
mustard and pickles oh my god the
dialogue in this movie so I can quit
talking about it I'm just gonna go ahead
and add another 50 sins here for the
remainder of the film we're never going
to see this doll actually move are we
like not even a blink because yeah I get
it it would be campy like child's play
if we actually got to see this doll do
her thing but I think it's just more
annoying than anything whoa oh oh if you
spent the money I think you did on this
doll surely it's a highly prized
sought-after item you should at least
try getting your money back or something
since it cost you a few months rent but
I guess we won't be able to see how
creepy the stall is if he doesn't just
simply toss it in the garbage no one
will be seated during this movie's 15
sewing scenes even though there's only
one burner that matters in this scenario
Annabelle turns them all on for maximum
nonsense by the way I know Mia can't see
the popcorn burning but why can't she
smell it would've offed everywhere in
the house they're pregnant super powers
should have been able to sniff this out
before even mortal men could ah that
gorgeous staple of modern horror the
invisible paranormal activity dragging
scene also is this a doll or is it just
a demon because I don't see the doll or
demon hand anywhere in this shop people
actually heard her scream ex machina
that girl we shall call her Jiffy Pop in
case you confused it with Pasadena New
Hampshire mothers are closer to God than
any other living creature oh yeah I
think I read that in Deuteronomy once
before this will be the prized photo in
my upskirt collection let's say how did
that get in there I swear it threw it
out wow I feel like I'm actually there
this guy's audition what am I supposed
to be afraid of in this movie and why
does she even bother walking around in
another room but the whole point is to
be a scary dick in the next room that is
a severe waste of spiritual energy if
this kid is so adamant about the no
strangers rules and why are these two
outside their apartment unattended in a
high-traffic area of the building where
many strangers will be passing by also
these kids never appear or are mentioned
in the film again so not sure what the
point of any of this was well feel free
to stop by anytime it's a good thing we
randomly saw each other at the apartment
complex at one time and I own a
bookstore that just happens to have a
book you'll need later and then I'm
alpha
meeow keeps getting drawings of a
scenario by which she and her baby are
going to get hit by a truck this is a
waste of time for a ghost for me and
especially me also how much time has
passed I was trying to figure out how
they could even afford their first house
and now they've somehow managed to get
out of their lease which surely would
have come with some sort of penalty and
get an apartment in Pasadena in what a
matter of days
I mean Mia has zero income and John is a
resident right if they don't show us a
behind the scenes illegal drug operation
John has going on at the hospital I'm
calling bull holy Sh that record player
started up by itself that is so scary
still stirring on record players but
while they ctrl-c ctrl-v up next killer
curtains child giggles as they run from
one place to another in a horror movie
cliche this stupid girl had Mia in a
perfect position to terrorize her not
thirty seconds ago and once again who
are we supposed to fear the grown woman
looking at the baby in the crib the doll
this kid father Perez and his camera get
me something concrete movie someone tell
me the ghost logic here some forces both
closing the door and running towards it
at the same time magic door turns little
girl ghosts into a grown woman ghost
because you should always run your
hauntings like a video game glitch since
I'm offering woodard I will appear
everywhere you guys go from now on if
you guys ever wanted to of the
neighborhood don't hesitate or just
start walking around the neighborhood
I'll find a way to be wherever you are
in the previous shot the doll was
looking directly at me as she put the
baby down
but in this close-up her head is turned
in a completely different direction also
we're almost an hour into this movie and
in a movie that promises lots of evil
doll shenanigans we have still had no
evil volatile issue count a sewing
machine turning on by itself and god
damn it I did not count that by my count
this is the four millionth time this has
happened in a horror movie I am certain
the filmmakers will get a prize for this
in a secret ceremony in Hollywood and
the virgin sacrifice will appease their
God probably copied from another guy
also Mia just walked out of the room how
far could she be down the hall before
the door started closing by itself
making a loud creaking noise the
investigation of this out of nowhere
baby carriage will require the rest of
the movie's runtime Nia has clearly
never seen a horror film and approaches
the Satanic looking baby carriage with
loud screaming emanating from it that
was not there before this might be scary
if the demon claw did anything other
than grabbing her wrist if this hellish
being can somehow control the elevator
why hasn't it won yet and why does it
even allow the elevator to close its
doors the mysteries of movie demons
demon dickhead forgets to lock the only
other exit out of this place
rendering all scares
here's my demons claw just in case you
decided to look down here at this very
moment did the demon put everyone in the
apartment complex to sleep or is MIA the
only person here that was clearly taken
before she got caught up in the cult um
why is her kid picture in this police
report when we heard about Annabel
runnin away from her parents we found
out that she was like 18 so the only
reason why they would show her kid
picture is because for some reason this
movie wants to have a scary scene
involving a kid changing into a girl
woman there was nothing special about
seeing Annabel when she was a kid so
because this here hello yeah you Mimi
and somehow snuck into Evelyn's
bookstore without the omnipresent
Evelyn running into her before this what
what do they want a soul and they won't
stop until they get one and from what I
see in these movies they won't start
until they get one wait come on the
demon can somehow tell the future if it
knows this was gonna happen surely it's
going to know how much of a failure it's
going to be 25 minutes from now
well since we find out that he wants me
a soul how about the murder of her baby
lead to that massive cheek we saw Mia
pushing the stroller no baby she drops
the keys then the carriage starts
rolling it was never a baby in her arms
this whole time until the big reveal and
surely the demon knew what was up or it
wouldn't have wasted our goddamn time
it's a good thing she has a bookstore
close by with not only an occult book
section but also a book with a chapter
titled the name of the cult that is
fucking with her Mia officially believes
in demons but leaves her baby just lying
on the floor she goes to investigate 4
million 1/4 million - there's nothing
scarier than when heavy books fall all
around your baby but I am relieved to
see this being from the depths of Hell
has horrible 8 or is from the part of
Hell where they don't believe in harming
kids so
it takes nearly 70 minutes for this
movie to Anabelle
somehow this scene his weight less
terrifying knowing that a demon is
controlling the doll like a less evil
Jeff Dunham also what's the point what's
the freaking point does it need the doll
what happened to human ghost demon
Annabel demon somehow knows not to be
there as soon as John opens the door
this is essentially at John ex machina
but it's more of an indictment of the
demons slow theatrics this dog may I see
it
so did Mina see the demon behind the
door or was that for our benefit why
does she think the doll is the problem
after all the things she's seen also
let's not forget let's not forget but
John and me and I used to have some
amazing thumb wars at first I thought it
was some fun character trait for the
couple to have but now I realize the
movie totally forgot it and it was some
cheap way to achieve something so even
though mia has seen this doll wielding
some crazy satanic abilities she still
took the time to place it back in her
freakin kid's room
his family deserves everything that
happens to them also in the original
supposedly true story this movie is
based on Annabelle was a Raggedy Ann
doll I get why they couldn't use that
doll for this movie but I feel they went
a little too far on the creepy look
factor this doll looks like it would
only be purchased by someone that's
hoping it will come to life and kill
other loved ones I still don't
understand what the doll has to do with
this supposed demon John would be
amazing at cinemasins
demons can sometimes use objects as
conduits to achieve their desired goal
except in this case it's ridiculously
ineffective and it's shown it has way
more power and doesn't need to use a
doll demons can't just take Souls Mia
soul needs to be offered to the demon
before I can take it
I guess the demon also hopes you'll
consult someone who's knowledgeable on
the subject so that you'll know what it
wants it's done a terrible job of
expressing that wish to Mia so far so I
wonder how it was ever supposed to get
what it wanted if it never told her the
very least I've heard of a married
couple that the church has worked with
in the past they were way too expensive
for this movie and there between
conjuring zatt the moment when we do in
the meantime and I can't have Leah
anywhere near that oh you tried getting
rid of it at one time and threw it in
the fucking garbage you didn't try
anything else and yet you think it's
hopeless
why not the trunk again I'm going to
hammer this
how does mian know it's the doll she's
experienced things with the actual demon
and with the actual Annabelle with no
doll attached but she sees the doll
float in the air once and the problem is
definitely that all
kind of baseball game is being played on
the west coast so late at night that
there aren't other people on the roads
so many questions damn this demon was
patient it waited that whole car ride to
do anything to father Perez how much it
wants that's why to take sure father
Perez plays the pronoun game but we've
already established the demon wants a
soul so why is it being said like it's a
big reveal
and she said it that I can't take this
you you said that it has to be offered
why did they ever think the demon wanted
Leah's soul and if I somehow missed that
why didn't they ever consider that the
demon wanted Mia's soul father Perez was
in an accident
he said demon can affect telephone
reception but I don't know how this
draws it any closer to getting me a soul
there I am leaving now someone hangs up
on you when you get a dial tone cliche
so the demon can impersonate father
Perez now this is where the t1000 this
demon only wasn't visible until now
because Mia and Evelyn were also looking
at the ceiling with the narrow geography
of a film camera and have no peripheral
vision so can the doll just appear out
of ether now it's supposed to be a
physical object right like the doll
itself has no powers but the demonic
presence inside of it does so how the
hell did the doll get back here without
anyone bringing it in and who was
adventurous enough to give this
hitchhiking doll a ride or did she walk
back ah red crayon god damn it's about
time you couldn't figure out the fucking
crayons you can stop elevators up
telephones closed doors with your minds
but crayons eluded you until now and why
so many of the same message were you
worried that if he wrote it only a
couple of times she wouldn't see it also
this is classic pronoun game later the
demon finally spells it out and says
your soul which I think could have been
crayon in the first 30 minutes of the
movie
tell her how she can give you what you
want I can make it right
this is what Ruby meant how do either of
these women know that this will bring
Leah back to Mia hella Mia is only going
off of one person's intuition but the
reason the demon is with you is it wants
a soul and she didn't even hear what
father Perez said to her husband in the
hospital also this seems like a very
convoluted way for a demon to collect a
soul instead of farting around for the
last couple weeks moving dolls around
and couldn't have just gone to me and
said so I'm going to take your baby and
the only way you're gonna save her is if
you give me your soul or someone else's
soul got it good also does the doll
actually have to do with this we saw the
blood go in the eye and we've seen
Annabelle's ghost appear around the doll
but Annabelle is not the demon that's
trying to collect the soul so does she
just happen to be around and even if we
are to assume that the cult raised this
demon or I think all of the other cult
members would may be aware of this and
hang out around Mia and their sheep
robes or whatever the cult members wore
back then also if any soul would do then
why didn't the demon also honk-honk are
you telling me only a female soul will
do that's racist God on their sacrifice
and our sacrifices touch God's heart and
move his head except maybe when your
sacrifice is to offer your soul to the
devil so we get one death this entire
movie after Pete and share and get
murdered basically off screen I mean
Annabelle and her Charles Manson boy toy
are killed but that just kicks the main
story in motion also these are the only
three deaths of any consequence in all
three of the film's so far made up in
the conjuring universe if all these
items are possessed in some form
shouldn't everything be encased in
something also I was not aware that
glass will protected us from giving up
our soul to bat crazy demons I guess
once this doll gets one soul it has the
patience to sit behind a glass case
until it's profitable to make a sequel
where the hell did you launch update at
TELUS evil I tell you I'm Chucky and I'm
here friend to the end
come look blow up the dam step No
[Music]
[Applause]
there's no baby was for cash yes